♪ GOING TO FIND OUT WHO'S
NAUGHTY OR NICE ♪
♪    ♪♪
>> Martha: WELCOME BACK TO OUR
SPECIAL.
"THE FIVE"'S FIRST EVER
GINGERBREAD HOUSE COMPETITION.
GREG IS SO EXCITED.
WHICH ONE OF US BUILT THE BEST
SWEET TREAT?
YOU BE THE JUDGE.
>> Juan: HEY, HEY, HEY YOU.
♪ ♪
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: ISN'T THAT GREAT?
>> DO YOU KNOW HOW TO DO A
GINGERBREAD ELF?
>> Juan: I DON'T.
AS LONG AS I HAVE YOU, I CAN DO
IT.
>> LET'S DO THAT.
>> ♪♪ JINGLE BELL, JINGLE BELLS,
JINGLE BELL ROCK ♪♪
>> Juan: WE HAVE GUMDROP LEAN
AND WE HAVE -- LOOK AT THESE
LITTLE GUYS.
HERE WE ARE.
DESSERT FOR CHRISTMAS DAY FROM
OUR FAMILY TO YOURS.
MERRY CHRISTMAS.
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS!
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK THIS
IS GOING TO GO SO WELL.
MARTHA, I NEED HELP WITH THIS.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE DOING.
>> Martha: YOU CALLED THE
WRONG PERSON.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE NOT GOOD AT
THIS?
>> Martha: NO BUT I AM SO
HAPPY TO TRY TO HELP YOU.
>> Jesse: SQUEEZED SOME OF
THAT STUFF ON THERE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE THE DOOR.
ONE, TWO.
>> Martha: YOU DID NOT GO TO
ARCHITECTURE SCHOOL, I AM
GUESSING.
>> Jesse: IT IS FOR TALL
PEOPLE.
I CAN PUT GUTFELD ON MY
SHOULDERS AND STILL GET IN THE
FRONT DOOR.
OH!
[LAUGHS]
[LAUGHTER]
PUT SOME ICING OVER HERE.
[LAUGHS]
OKAY.
OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK IT'S DONE.
I THINK WE ARE FINISHED.
>> Dana: I CHOSE A DOG HOUSE,
THE BEST KIND OF HOUSE UNLESS
YOU ARE JESSE AND GROGG.
THEN THE DOG HOUSE IS NOT FUN.
THE DOG HOUSE AT MY HOUSE IS
ALWAYS FUN.
JASPER OF COURSE.
THIS FANCY DOODAD.
IT KIND OF LOOKS LIKE JASPER A
LITTLE BIT.
RIGHT HERE.
AND A S FOR SPIKE.
PRETTY GOOD, RIGHT?
IT'S A DOG HOUSE.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW I LOVE THE
CHRISTMAS SEASON.
I SPENT A LOT OF TIME BUILDING
MY OWN SPECIAL GINGERBREAD HOUSE
AND THEN I THREW IT AWAY.
SO HERE IT IS.
THE ONE I AM DOING NOW.
LOOK WHAT I DID.
ISN'T IT BEAUTIFUL?
I JUST WHIPPED IT TOGETHER JUST
FOR YOU.
OH, JEEZ.
WHAT DID I DO?
OH, MY GOD.
I GUESS THERE IS NO TAKE TWO.
WHAT I LEARNED IS IF YOU DON'T
WANT TO DO IT AGAIN, RUIN THE
PROJECT SO THEY CAN'T DO A
SECOND TAKE.
>> Juan: YOU DID THAT
INTENTIONALLY.
>> Greg: IT WAS BY ACCIDENT.
>> Dana: MARTHA, AT YOUR
HOUSE, DO YOU LET YOUR CHILDREN
EAT THE GINGERBREAD HOUSE OR IS
IT JUST FOR SHOW?
>> Martha: I LOVE GINGERBREAD
HOUSES BUT I'M NOT GOOD AT
MAKING THEM COME AS WE ALL NOW
KNOW.
WE DEFINITELY HAVE MADE THEM
OVER THE YEARS.
YOU CAN BREAK THEM APART AND EAT
THEM.
IF IT'S A REAL ONE.
I LOVE GINGERBREAD.
>> Jesse: I LIKE THE ICING.
I WOULD SQUEEZE IT INTO MY
MOUTH.
I LIKE SQUEEZING THAT THING.
WHAT WOULD YOU CALL THAT THING
THAT YOU SQUEEZE?
FROSTING SQUEEZER.
I LOVE IT.
IT'S REALLY ACCURATE.
I FEEL LIKE PICASSO.
IT IS >> Greg: YOU GOT IN ON
YOUR SUIT.
>> Jesse: A LITTLE SLOPPY.
>> Martha: IT STARTED SHOOTING
OUT THE OTHER SIDE.
>> Dana: MARTHA IS LIKE "I
HAVE A REAL SHOW."
>> Greg: JUAN, BEING A
DEMOCRAT, YOUR GINGERBREAD HOUSE
HAD NO FRIENDS.
>> Juan: BECAUSE MY SON-IN-LAW
IS AN ARCHITECT, WE HAD
>> Jesse: WHO IS THAT?
HE IS A STAR?
GREAT TIMING.
>> Greg: THAT HER HAIR THAN
JESSE.
>> Jesse: LET'S NOT GO THAT
FAR.
>> Greg: I GUESS THE AUDIENCE
VOTES AND WE WILL KNOW BY THE
END OF THE SHOW.
RIGHT, PRODUCERS?
>> Martha: I AM VOTING FOR
JUAN.
>> Greg: WE HAVE SOMEONE
TABULATING.
WE WILL HAVE SOME OF YOUR
COMMENTS TOO.
>> Juan: GREG, IF THEY PICK
YOURS, THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO